en español quisiera preguntarle en
primer lugar Qué efectos y qué
repercusiones pueden tener estas medidas
para los británicos
no yo creo que lo primero Muchas gracias
es darse cuenta de que estas medidas
Pues hacen muy poco para mejorar la
estabilidad fiscal el gran problema del
déficit estructural del Reino Unido
viene fundamentalmente del aumento de
gasto constante que se ha llevado a cabo
en los últimos años y además ante una
recesión reconocida por el propio
gobierno Aumentar los impuestos y a la
vez reducir los gastos pues es
contractivo Y eso lo hemos vivido en
otras economías en Europa en otras
ocasiones por lo tanto El Gran riesgo de
este paquete fiscal anunciado es que el
impacto negativo sobre la economía sea
mayor y que el impacto en cuanto a
reducción del déficit fiscal sea muy
pequeño ahora la ex primera ministra que
Europa con el cargo no listos no tuvo
ningún tipo de éxito Con su plan
económico que tiene este plan nuevo que
lo diferencia
el gran factor diferencial de este plan
económico con respecto al Release es que
parece más un plan económico que hubiera
presentado él el partido de la oposición
el partido laborista a un plan de
gobierno conservador no al gobierno
conservador normalmente es un gobierno
más fiscalmente responsable en cuanto a
gasto y más fiscalmente
expansivo en cuanto a reducciones de
impuestos por lo tanto
probabilidades de que salga adelante
Pues sí puede que salga adelante yo creo
que el gran problema en cualquier caso
es que no es un plan efectivo ni desde
el punto de vista de fiscal ni mucho
menos para sacar al país de la recesión
ahora como decíamos no antes de
presentarlo la compañía energéticas ven
aumentado sus impuestos por lo que parte
del plan recae sobre ellas no Qué
consecuencias Podría tener esto en el
sector energético y también para los
consumidores
bueno históricamente sabemos que las
subidas de impuestos a las empresas
energéticas siempre recaen en los
consumidores de una manera o de otra o
es menor inversión O es mayor precios
pero ya hemos demostrado en la última en
la última publicación No que por ejemplo
pues las grandes empresas energéticas
pues no han pagado ese impuesto
extraordinario porque no han tenido
beneficios extraordinarios en el Reino
Unido las empresas energéticas Aunque
tengan sede en el Reino Unido son
empresas globales shell PP que vemos en
el en el en las imágenes Ahora son
empresas que tienen la inmensa mayoría
de sus beneficios en otros países por lo
tanto los beneficios que generan el
Reino Unido son muy pequeños el impacto
no es positivo no es positivo porque
claro genera también la posibilidad de
que estas empresas decidan trasladar su
sede a otro país ya que no no hay un
beneficio no solamente fiscal sino
operativo